pour ton mariage avant de tourner la
page et de quitter la famille soit
fidèle à ton amour tu sais que je t'aime
alors n'ai pas trop de tijd je suis ta
petite fille pour toujours
que la vie passe bien vite ne pleure pas
je te revois petit c'est avec toi que
j'ai ouvert mon coeur à tous les secret
du bonheur quand on partait tous les
deux main dans la main comme on était
heureux sur serein
tous les enfants semblent un beau monde
il ya dix ans quand tu as écrit cette
chanson c'est en fait qu'un jour on la
chante ensemble un bien franchement non
mais par contre je sais pas si tu te
rappelles
j'ai une bonne mémoire quand il écrit la
chanson pour ilan it ok c'est une
chanteuse israélienne rappelle blonde
qui passait à l'olympia avec moi et toi
tu avais drôlement aimé la chanson mais
c'était aussi un peu jalouse rappel
était tout petit c'était jalouse alors
je t'ai dit écoute ne t'inquiète pas
quand tu seras grande et petite mariera
en la chantera ensemble et c'est toi qui
me l'a rappelé la veille du mariage et
on a chanté à l'occasion du mariage mais
jamais j'aurais cru qu'on allait le
faire à l'olympia et tout ça c'était pas
du tout et les guider moi j'ai par
contre j'ai un petit reproche à faire
pourquoi ta mis si longtemps pour me
dire que tu voulais être chanteuse koxie
pas parce que j'avais honte voilà je
vais l'accueillir
et pourtant tu sais bien que tu aurais
jamais refusé ben oui mais c'était pas
le moment ce juriste et puis voilà quoi
j'avais très envie de chanter une
chanson avec toi depuis très longtemps
l ai trouvé mon registre c'est à dire
que comme on dit en anglais ce de
reitmans strike
ouais dis moi chérie et cet album que tu
prépares il en est où
mais pour l'instant il en est qu'au
stade de maquette quoi je travaille pour
l'instant pas parler d'album comme étant
je travaille j'ai beaucoup de travail
la cour est ce que je t'en ai fait voir
pendant monnaie d'échangé bah moi chez
les jeux que tu bois tu as fait voir
mais enfin pas méchamment mais et ces
moments bon tu m'as les études tu ne les
a complètement raté et c'est donc moi je
suis un ancien instituteur je voulais
que tu réussisses dans dans les études
vous est peut-être le nom des communes a
passé son bac d'accord mais les ratés ça
suffit pas tu sais bien que ça suffit
pas mais malgré ça je dois dire que je
n'ai jamais faire de différence entre
toi et ton frère et avec corinne aussi
que comme ta soeur tu le sais bien
je voulais pas et finalement malgré tout
ce que tu m'en a fait voir
j'ai un faible pour toi j'ai pas peur de
le dire pudiquement le pire coup ce que
je t'ai fait c'était quoi le pire truc
c'est quand tu es en réaliser une
surboum en cash and le mois alors là je
me suis imaginé tout tout tout le macho
que je suis alors là que tu vas savoir
ce que ça depuis les 20 ma tête
d'ailleurs tu te rappelles s'est donné
une bonne pas mais c'était un peu le
boxon dernier quoi il y avait beaucoup
de doigté
comment tu as dit le bois ça me met les
boules de voir qu'est-ce qui t'énerve
plus en moi
de temps en temps tu es un peu
capricieuse et ça ça me plaît pas voilà
c'est tout allez me dire que c'était ce
que je comprends pas les inclusions prêt
à bas serait aussi mais ya pas que ça
cas pas comme ça le truc c est moi alors
qu'est-ce qui t'énerve le plus en moi ce
qui m'énerve le plus en toi c'est que je
te trouve un peu lunatique parfois c'est
qu'il faut presque prendre rendez vous
pour parler parfois pendant la salat
exagère j'accepte de pâques c'est là où
j'accepte c'est quand tu dis que je suis
lunatique mais parfois ça rend ça me
rend un peu paranoïaque en fait parce
que je crois que le mal qu est-ce qui
sont l'un des grands mon avis on demand
le choc comme chérie quelle question
mon nom son nombre de voix la trêve est
ce qu'une femme est content si belle
soit fidèle à ton amour mais tactile ne
craint pas là
tu dois je viendrai colavitti de chaque
jour que de bonheur partagé tout outil
qui semble s'éloigner mais aujourd'hui
c'est un grand jour de joie qui nous
jettent ou s'ouvrir les bras